not a ton of surprises today beside the
fact that they very much focused on one
single product you don't often see Apple
have an entire event around just one
product a macbook pro that only
represents such a slim percentage of the
company's overall revenues in terms of
what I found interesting i think that
the touch bar as you mentioned at the
beginning the show is very interesting
because you can build applications in
there allowing developers to do this as
well so it's not just for Apple's first
party apps so this might create an
ecosystem of new applications that
basically merge between this touch
screen and the actual you know screen on
laptop there were some negative
reactions to the touch bar you know
tweets like we waited this long and all
that's new is a touch bar shouldn't it
be placed lower by the trackpad it's
going to be awkward Ben what do you
think I mean I think you know when you
look at what Apple's doing and
interestingly i think the touch bar is
sort of an admission on their behalf
that some sort of a touch experience
belongs on you know or clamshell right
people have argued about this for a long
time Apple said we're not going to put
touch on macbooks there were pcs
themselves but this is a recognition
that there are some things that are
nicer when you can use your finger and
so I thought it made sense right
philosophically they're saying you know
move your fingers forward keep you keep
the touch where your fingers are versus
going like this and that makes some
sense so it really just comes down to
the workflow you know how do people
prefer to use these things at any time
we see just looking at you know what
Microsoft did and what Apple did any
time we see innovations in hardware it's
it's designed to create innovations in
softcore so really both of these
products are depending on what the
software community does with the things
that they're now enabling whether that's
a big touchscreen and a pen and a dial
or the touch bar it's really the
software community that's going to
advance that feature meaningfully so
what's your take on Microsoft vs apple
this week I mean I think a couple things
I mean overall I mean I think Microsoft
was not just a you know a hardware
surface again I think for windows they
did a ton to move the Windows platform
forward and I think that's important
because again right if we just look at
the two companies there's exponentially
more people consumers and workers who
are on Windows then on Max and I think
the way that they're starting to sort of
come away from this like her own
activities just excel and and they're
getting more exciting about creativity
in 3d and you can see some hollow lens
stuff that's on the roadmap for
exterior at three hundred bucks that's
pretty exciting for the windows
ecosystem so I think they did a lot to
move the windows ecosystem forward mark
I would have to agree i think they're
working on two different spectrums here
in terms of their computers microsoft
came out with this surface studio which
basically looks like an apple patent
from four years ago where you can you
know use it like a normal desktop
computer like an iMac and then push it
down and draw with it as the cool dial
it's very interesting that Apple decided
clearly for whatever reason not to take
that approach with the imac in terms of
the macbook pro it's a totally different
direction than the latest microsoft
laptops i've been testing one and you
can either have been in a clamshell mode
like a normal laptop at the keyboard
touch the screen or you can pop this you
know the device off and it's like you
have a laptop when you want to laptop
and then you have a tablet when you want
to tablet instead Apple it wants to sell
you both from a financial perspective
that's the way to do it for Apple a
company that's worth more than any other
tech company in the world but for a
convenient standpoint some people might
like the Microsoft approach but of
course hardware is starting to become a
little bit more commoditized anyone can
get OLED technology anyone can get
processors anyone can build their own
graphics engines now as you see the
google pixel phone it really comes down
to the software if you want to be part
of the Windows platform do want to be
part of the Android platform or do you
want to be part of the iOS platform